good morning john so writing fiction is
hard and weird and i have found that it
is a very important thing
to identify something about my fictional
characters not their star sign it's not
whether they're an intp
not really what they value it's not
really their identity it's like an
overlap between those two things i have
a hard time articulating it probably
because
sociologists will roll their eyes at me
and be like it's way more complicated
than that hank but it is the overlap
between the attributes that they think
are positive and the attributes that
they think they have it's the stuff
about them
that they think is valuable the reasons
why they think they matter and i've also
found this to be a useful thing to
understand about myself
and the people who are important to me
and also like
people who are important to my society
so here's how i kind of feel like this
works society is like here are
the positive attributes pick a few and
have them be
yours and maybe you're lucky and a
couple of those things fit like a real
nice new shirt and then you can feel
like you matter
other times people will find that there
isn't a lot of overlap between the
things that they've been told are
valuable
and the way that they actually are or
the opportunities that they've been
given and that sucks
it doesn't mean that you can't figure
out how and why you matter it just means
that you kind of have to like
figure it out on your own you have to
make some things up and have them not be
the
the default things that society has
presented to you here are a few more
things that this line of thinking has
brought to me the traits that you
believe are valuable about yourself
are really important to your self-worth
and so if somebody threatens that
it can feel like an assault and it
sometimes happens with attributes that
like one person doesn't think is that
big of a deal and the other person
thinks is like the
only reason they matter in the world and
that can cause
some tension second any given culture
will have a lot of strong opinions about
which traits are really valuable
and it is much easier to go with
your culture's beliefs than to try and
define it all on your own and third
there is good stuff about all of the
traits that people value
that's why we value them there are
however also definitely some worrying
things about some of them this has all
been ridiculously abstract so far so
let's just let's list some traits beauty
intelligence ancestry strength wit care
kindness wealth
selflessness curiosity loyalty grit
independence mastery of skill winning
focus
how well we conform to expectations of
social roles like gender family and
career
being part of groups like teams or
citizens or friend groups or political
parties and depending on how you're
raised the stories you hear the default
expectations of your culture
the attributes you end up believing in
may or may not be attributes that you
can actually embody and sometimes
they're things that you can only embody
for
a specific period of your life and then
you won't be able to do it anymore as
humans we need
to believe we matter and so i'm hesitant
to say that these things are subjective
but they are from my point of view there
is no mattering
outside of in here it's just the story
we find most compelling whether it's the
reckless individualism of thomas edison
or the thoughtful kindness of a teacher
or parent we believe
in the stories we find ourselves in
sometimes
those stories make us miserable
sometimes we don't match them sometimes
we grow beyond them
sometimes the world changes and they
become less useful and do more harm than
good if i have any wisdom to share here
it's that these things are not carved in
copper these things can change and they
should and that should never
make you feel less worthwhile it should
make you
feel human because of all of the
exceptional things
about humans the amazing traits that we
have
the one that is most human is
adaptability what matters to you
the stories you find yourself in how you
imagine your value
all of those things can change and all
of them
will john i'll see you tomorrow
pizza mess fanny pack fanny pack
it's got a zipper in the front and a
zipper in the back
fanny pack fanny pack hmm that was a lot